bonjour mesdames bonjour mademoiselle
bonjour messieurs à partir d'aujourd'hui
télé midi change de formule c'est
surtout au cours des jours à venir que
vous remarquerez un certain nombre de
modifications au cours de la deuxième
partie de ce journal vous proposeront
des magazines certains nous parviendrons
de nos correspondants en province qui
sillonne toute la france ce sera le
reflet des activités du pays le magazine
féminin n'ayant en étant plus diffusée
le lundi soir à 18h30
nous vous proposerons mais d'armes des
sujets féminins des rubriques féminine
qui vous seront proposées tous les jours
donc à 7 et les midi le lundi vous aurez
un conseil culinaire le mardi une
chronique juridique le mercredi une
enquête sociale quant aux jeudis nous
aborderons le problème des enfants le
vendredi la mode et le samedi dimanche
des problèmes intéressants toute la
famille en ce qui concerne la boue tous
ceux qui s'y intéressent seront ravis
car la rubrique sera également plus
longue et plus complet l'actualité dans
le monde sera toujours diffusée en début
de programme c'est pourquoi dans un vol
caire et jean-michel leniaud je cède dès
maintenant la parole je cède à vous
n'est ce pas pour le ski on va commencer
par ça les informations mais il est
grand surprise d'abord à val gardena
aujourd'hui c'était la première manche
du slalom géant messieurs la deuxième
manche aura lieu demain est certain que
les français n'ont pas joué de chance
comme ce fut le cas hier dans cette
première manche pourquoi parce que deux
autres chiens sont en tête vous avez
peut-être suivi tout à l'heure le direct
de jacques perron à val gardena
pour l'instant ce sécheresse qui est en
tête devant ben les nerfs les deux de
nationalité autrichienne
qu'est-il arrivé aux français nous
allons voir tout à l'heure en images une
chute presque une chute de patrick
roussel en tout cas un petit incident
qui lui a fait perdre au moins une
seconde alors qu'il était très très bien
placé mais tout n'est pas perdu pour
l'instant nous avons jean noël augert
encore lui on peut dire qui est en
quatrième position je vous propose en
images
cela parle beaucoup mieux peut être que
nos commentaires de voir tout d'abord
russell et ensuite france ou celle qui
était parti avec le dossard numéro 3
alors qu'il avait été précédée dans
l'ordre par turenne holly l'un des
favoris et bruckmann voici recel dans
dix secondes maintenant quinze secondes
au sel va faire une faute dans une porte
vous allez le voir il va certes très
bien se rattraper il était alors
en troisième position au temps
intermédiaire puisqu'il avait été
crédité de 49 53 49 secondes 53
centièmes devancé seulement par liner 49
11 qui étaient d'ailleurs partis
derrière lui et par franz 49 21
voilà l'incident voyez que russell
remonte passe la porte quand même donc
il ne sera pas disqualifié il
participera par conséquent à la deuxième
manche demain mais dans l'incident
rossellat dû perdre vraisemblablement au
moins une seconde son temps est
actuellement de 2 minutes 17 secondes 99
centièmes vous apercevez tout de suite
de la longueur inhabituelle de ce géant
car normalement un géant ce chronomètre
on peut le dire en moins de deux minutes
mais là les italiens ont choisi une
pente très très longue avec quelques
difficultés surtout en fin de parcours
des portes qui tourne énormément
et voici je rentre maintenant au même
endroit l'endroit même où nous avions
pris russell tout à l'heure vous allez
voir que 38 ne va pas faire de faute
son temps indique d'ailleurs 2 15 15
une très nette supériorité 30 c'est donc
pour l'instant en tête de cette première
manche oublions pas que le géant secours
en deux manches et lunaire vont
évidemment joué un grand rôle
avant demain 1er france de 15,15
deuxième blenner autriche à 30 centièmes
troisième giovanoli le suisse qui était
parti avec le dossard numéro 1 à 96
centièmes
un homme à surveiller s'il faut d'ores
et déjà se donner un favori je pense
tout particulièrement à giovanoli 4e
jean noël augert à une seconde 60
centièmes un lourd handicap pour demain
5e tischhauser le suisse a une seconde
68 centièmes alors que voyons les
derniers mètres les dernières portes de
karl schranz que l'on n'attendait pas
ici pourquoi parce que je crois que
quatrième au classement actuel dé slalom
géant de la coupe du monde
devancé par tony giovanoli et russell
quant à russell et bien il a un handicap
je vous disais tout à l'heure assez
lourd à surmonter de deux secondes 84
centièmes nos seules chances demain
jean noël augert avec exactement une
seconde 60 centièmes de retard sur
l'inusable france
voilà pour le ski merci beaucoup nous
passons maintenant à la politique avec
duke laisse en effet il a eu hier des
élections municipales à nancy il ya
ballottage et ce qui est à remarquer
tout d'abord je crois ce nombre élevé d
abstention il ya eu près de 50%
d'abstention les nancéiens ont donc des
les urnes c'est un peu normal au premier
tour d'une élection municipale très
disputée les pronostics sont confirmés
oui il ya là c'est la liste centriste du
sénateur marcel martin
qui est en tête et elle a de fortes
chances de prendre la mairie à la
coalition eu des républicains
indépendants que conduisait le député
udf rejet social et deux autres députés
de la majorité dont l'ancien maire dr
weber il remarque également la poussée
du ps eu oui c'est une légère surprise
le psg gagne près de 900 voix et il
devance la liste du parti communiste
cette réussite du psg à nancy
rappel mais évidemment le succès de
monsieur michel rocard dans les yvelines
monsieur rocard ou de monsieur de
murville est d'ailleurs le chef de file
du ps eut à nancy monsieur françois
borella est un personnage qui rappelle
un peu monsieur rocard c'est un
professeur de droit il a une quarantaine
d'années à peine et sept îles et du
genre intellectuelle bouillonnant 10 le
ps eu en tout cas semble parti pour
récupérer en diverses régions les voix
d'un certain nombre d'anciens électeurs
socialistes il progresse régulièrement
et c'est une situation qui peut à la
longue peser sur le rapport des forces
entre les partis de gauche dont le
prochain tour et pour dimanche prochain
comment se présente la situation en deux
mots et bien le pc s'est retiré ils
resteront par principe quatre listes
mais il peut encore y avoir des retraits
le favori est évidemment le docteur
martin nous aurons toute la semaine pour
en parler le congrès du parti communiste
lui s'est terminée dimanche
et qu'est ce que l'on peut dire
aujourd'hui de monsieur garaudy attend
des nouvelles eh bien on se demandait si
monsieur blaireau 17 enfants terribles
du pc allait rester tranquilles ou bien
s'il allait relancer le débat et bien on
a appris ce matin que monsieur garaudy
annulait la conférence de presse qu'il
devait faire demain en raison de son
état de santé sur les conseils de son
médecin de son médecin vous de monsieur
marché ce qui est certain c'est que s'il
continuait la polémique que monsieur
garaudy risquer de se faire exclure
définitivement du parti communiste et il
n'a certainement pas envie signale aussi
que la pravda commente encore ce matin
le congrès du parti communiste et elle
se félicite de son monolithisme merci
beaucoup
nous passons maintenant à l'actualité
internationale au proche orient il ya
toujours des accrochages des incidents
un raid à signaler aujourd'hui de
l'aviation égyptienne sur des positions
israéliennes en territoires occupés au
caire la conférence le petit sommet
arabe se poursuit on attend des
décisions pour aujourd'hui
gérard ce malgré nous en parler de suite
en effet ce matin 11h au caire s'est
tenue la dernière séance du petit sommet
arabe séance au cours de laquelle a été
rédigé le communiqué final que nous
venons de recevoir et que je vous donne
la conférence des pays dits du champ de
bataille réaffirme sa détermination de
libérer les terres arables spoliés et sa
conviction profonde de la victoire il
semble que les travaux de cette
conférence aboutiront aussi à une
augmentation de la coopération militaire
entre le front occidental égyptien le
front oriental jordanie et syrie
théoriquement le ministre égyptien de la
guerre le général faouzi et le
commandant en chef des trois armées mais
jusqu'à présent il n'y a jamais eu de
véritable coordination devant l'ensemble
des chefs d'état arabes le colonel
faouzi aurait surtout également mis
l'action sur la supériorité aérienne d
israël
toujours à l'étranger mystère à calcutta
en inde
on se demande pourquoi la femme du
consul général de france là-bas a été
assassiné je rappelle que dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche trois inconnus ont
pénétré dans la résidence du consul
qu'ils ont première des ainsi que sa
femme et leur fils madame défaite est
morte le consul est dans un état grave
son fils est hors de danger
il semble que le vol n'était pas le
mobile de ce crime les agresseurs n'ont
en effet rien apporté
la police serait sur une piste car un
des domestiques a été arrêté c'est tout
ce que l'on sait ce matin nous passons
maintenant en angleterre avec une autre
affaire criminelle peut être criminel on
ne sait pas encore qui donne en tout cas
beaucoup de fil à retordre à la police
oui mais là aussi la police semble enfin
tenir une piste deux hommes sont
interrogés dans leurs locaux à kingston
dans le serait il semble qu'une série de
lettres et de coups de téléphones
adressés à monsieur mackay est permis de
réunir un dossier qui a amené ce
rebondissement de l'an iv
mais mme adam mckay demeure toujours
introuvable quelque 200 policiers sont
occupés à retourner le sol et a passé au
peigne fin la ferme au nord de long dans
laquelle vivait l'un des deux hommes
deux et ont été sondées l'on envisage de
les vider
mme adam mckay a disparu le 29 décembre
soir six heures plus tard un coup de
téléphone informé son époux de saône
enlèvement et lui réclamait un million
de livres puis plus rien on fait
monsieur mac et la police demeure est en
contacts téléphoniques avec les
ravisseurs qui au fil des semaines à
baisser leurs prétentions
la brigade criminelle se montre discrète
sur ses recherches de visiteurs de
marque son arrivée à strasbourg
aujourd'hui il s'agit du prince philip
le duc d'edimbourg et du prince de
galles saisir le prince charles il le
participe à l'ouverture la conférence
européenne sur la conservation de la
nature à noter qu'ils sont arrivés à
strasbourg en pilotant eux mêmes leurs
avions les informations générales
maintenant à amiens un grave accident de
la route s'est d'ailleurs le plus grave
enregistrée depuis le début de cette
année
consternation ce matin dans la région
amiénoise après le tragique accident
survenu hier en fin de soirée à saint
fuscien quelques kilomètres d'amiens
pour une raison encore indéterminée deux
voitures se sont heurtés de front
bilan sept morts un blessé c'est un
spectacle horrible qu'elle devait
trouver les pompiers il fallu employer
un chalumeau pour sortir les victimes de
la 204 disloqué trois femmes tuées sur
le coup
puis deux enfants tués également enfin
un troisième enfant devait succomber
pendant son transport à l'hôpital
l'aîné des enfants avec cinq ans dans
l'autre voiture une puissante alfa romeo
de litres 5-1 tué et sa passagère
légèrement blessé semble-t-il détail
navrant
l'épousé du conducteur de l'alfa romeo
suivait celle ci dans une voiture
appartenant à des amis je reviens
rapidement sur la politique
internationale pour dire un mot du petit
sommet du caire
une dépêche pas en effet nous parvenir
et c'est un communiqué le communiqué
final de cette réunion en appuyant
constamment israël les états unis expose
la paix et la sécurité du proche orient
et la paix du monde un grave danger il
assume ta c'est une grave responsabilité
devant la communauté internationale tout
entière dit ce communiqué revenons aux
informations générales à la route pour
signaler que la route de bourg saint
maurice à val d'isère qui avait été je
crois que vous en souvenez fermé hier
pour la nuit
par crainte d'avalanche a été rouvert ce
matin d'autre part l'embranchement de
ting a également été rendue à la
circulation
la station n'est donc plus isolé le
froid a permis ce matin la réouverture
de plusieurs pistes les hivernants qui
était contraint à l'inaction depuis cinq
jours et bien il semble qu'ils se
défoulent
ce matin les efforts pour retrouver les
quatre jeunes fait le loft bruxellois
bloqué dans une loge en couvrent des
ardennes belges ont jusqu'à présent été
vains il ya 120 sauveteurs sur place
en allemagne c'est l'épidémie de variole
qui inquiète en ce moment la population
il ya plus que le froid et la neige
jean pierre elkabbach ou sans fin trois
cents personnes atteintes de variole
sont aujourd'hui isolé dans ses stations
de quarantaine en dix jours les cas se
sont multipliés
trois d'entre eux sont devenus immortels
à l'origine un allemand de 20 ans parti
à la recherche de la sagesse en
compagnie de hippies de son âge il est
rentré de katmandou avec la variole la
colère et la peur sont abattues sur mais
chez de sa ville dans le sauerland à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres du bassin du
riel peuplé de la ruhr c'est maintenant
une ville morte
coupé du pays et seulement occupés par
les organisations sanitaires allemandes
et mondial en république fédérale
les mesures sont exemplaires et efficace
on vaccine partout dans les aérogares
comme dans les hôpitaux
jusqu'ici le traitement a limité sur le
plan local
l'épidémie de variole à 16 cas cent
cinquante mille enfants et adultes sont
en cours de vaccination grâce à
l'assistance du corps médical et le
vaccin arrive et d'urgence de toutes les
villes voisines mais je ne se passera
cette année de carnaval ses habitants
sont traités comme des pestiférés la
peur s'étend à la province mais le
moment critique de cette épidémie
exceptionnel sens maintenant passé
c'est en février 1946 qui a été
inaugurée la liaison aérienne régulière
entre washington et paris la même
compagnie a fêté cet anniversaire hier
en faisant atterrir à orly un de ces
nouveaux avions géants un jumbo jet et
jalousie a pu visiter cet avion voici ce
géant de la twofour54 à l'heure sur près
de 9000 km de rayon d'action avec un
nombre de passagers pouvant aller
jusqu'à 490 chiffre déjà connu mais
toujours étonnant l'aéroport d'orly et
celui au monde qui est prêt le premier à
accueillir de pareilles géant de l'air
dirigeants de l'as twl ont souligné hier
encore quel contraste tout de même avec
le vol d'il ya 24 ans mon père il ya 24
ans et un jour vous étiez l'une des
passagères du premier vol qui traversait
l'atlantique entre paris et new york
c'était une lendemain de la guerre en
1946 en continu un petit peu ce vol ce
voyage ces étapes et bien vous mariez
moi nous nous embarquions pour new york
par le premier vol transatlantique de
l'attitude peu v1 et c'était vraiment
une grande aventure à tous points de vue
combien y at il de temps de vol et nous
avons mis un peu plus de 21h et à bord
combien de passagers étiez vous et nous
étions être empêché cette passagère
d'autres fois nous l'avons interviewé
dans le bar salon des premières classes
dans tout l'appareil tout est à l'image
de la taille de ce géant est aussi
agrémenté de gadgets qui facilite le
service pour nous un passager cobayes
lecomte philippe de la fayette qui est
tout prêt à prendre par la voie des airs
le chemin que suivi autres poissons
ancêtres par-dessus ranger l'inventaire
du confort des sièges offerts par la cw
est confortée
oui notre lumière
oui ou l'incliner votre siège plus
yugurten la partie inférieure la musique
en vol 342 place dans cette version de
l'appareil
le boeing 747 premier d'une nouvelle
génération d'avions espérons qu étant
donné le nombre de places disponibles
dans cet avion le prix des avions va
diminuer voici donc notre deuxième sujet
magazine les produits surgelés
on en parle beaucoup on en consomme
encore assez peu nous avons voulu savoir
pourquoi malgré la variété des produits
surgelés proposés sur le marché français
c'est un des pays qui en consomment le
moins différentes raisons à cela
points de ventes insuffisant
compartiment grand froid longtemps trop
cher et surtout un manque d'information
du consommateur
comment doit-on acheter stocker et
utiliser les produits surgelés et tout
d'abord qu'est ce qu'un produit surgelé
bien un produit surgelé c'est un produit
de premier choix qui a été soumis très
vite après sa pêche ou après sa récolte
à très basse température de telle
manière que le coeur de l'aliment
atteignent rapidement moins 18 degrés
centigrades ainsi on peut avoir des
produits qu'ils conservent très
longtemps s'ils sont conservés
normalement comme ils doivent l'être
leur fraîcheur et leur saveur les gens
ne savent pas exactement ce que sont les
surgelés ni comment on les utilise les
mêmes choisis
expliquer exactement ce que nous devons
faire lorsqu'on achète un produit
surgelé il ya évidemment un certain
nombre de vérifications à faire jeter un
petit coup d'oeil déjà aux magasins et
aux meubles où on achète pour être
certain que on est dans de bonnes
conditions dans celle de la chaîne du
froid moins 18 degrés et ensuite il y à
un certain nombre de mentions l'on doit
trouver sur les emballages et la
première c'est la mention surgelés
ensuite les paquets doivent reporter
mention du poids en grammes et de ce
qu'il ya dedans ou de la composition
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un plat plus cuisiner
et il existe également une date qui est
marqué sur le paquet et qu'il est la
date de surgélation quel est l'intérêt
économique pour une ménagère vers les
intérêts économiques sont divers tout
d'abord en toute saison et en tout lieu
vous pouvez consommer à peu près
n'importe quel produit
ensuite il ya un intérêt qui touchent
directement le portefeuille de
l'aménageur c'est que les prix des
produits surgelés ont été stabilisées au
moment du meilleur court et tous ces
produits surgelés ont-ils les valeurs
nutritives que les produits frais oui
absolument à une précision frais c'est
la valeur nutritive du produit frais
lorsqu'il est au maximum de sa valeur
nutritive puisqu'on a surgelé le produit
le légume ou le poisson très rapidement
après la récolte dans vos romans où il a
sa valeur nutritive maximale sur le plan
des protéines par exemple lancé surtout
pour le poisson que cela joue
eh bien c'est exactement la même qualité
que pour un poisson frais et ont fait
d'être souvent un reproche aux poissons
surgelés en 10 il n'a pas de bruit n'a
pas d'odeur ce poisson bcm qui peut
trouver que la mariée faubel c'est
justement parce qu'il est très frais
qu'il n'a pas d'odeur
alors une ménagère qui achètent un
produit surgelé que peut-elle en faire
dans l'immédiat tout d'abord et elle
peut bien sûr le consommer le jour même
à midi ou le soir en fin d'année
je vais l'acheter ça va pas poser de
problème du tout elle peut le consommer
dans les deux ou trois jours pour ça il
faut tout de même qu'elle est un
réfrigérateur avec un freezer allumé le
produit dans son viseur et puis elle
peut et c'est même là le décès la
vocation du produit surgelé elle veut le
stocker pendant plusieurs mois
mais là il va y avoir un certain nombre
de conditions la première est d'acheter
à sac isotherme ce n'est pas une grosse
mise de fonds se doit être entre 15 et
20 francs de faire son marché des
surgelés tout à fait en dernier lieu
donc pour qu'il reste le moins longtemps
possible d'en acheter le plus possible à
la fois comme système bien froid dans
leur sac isotherme de rentrer chez soi
tout de suite et de les mettre
immédiatement dans un compartiment de
rouvroy vous décidez de faire un plat
surgelé vous le sortez du compartiment
grand froid
comment le disais j'ai d'abord il ne
faut pas changer d'avis parce que si les
sorties du compartiment grand froid
depuis un certain temps et bien il ne
faut pas leur mettre ensuite eh bien
c'est extrêmement simple vous sortez
votre produit de l'emballage et vous le
faites cuire directement au four dans la
poêle dans la casserole au
court-bouillon enfin comme vous avez
choisi de le faire et ça va très vite
c'est très très très facile alors il ya
quelques exceptions les fruits les
patins à roulettes il faut faire dégeler
hélas il ne faut pas vouloir aller trop
vite c'est à dire vouloir les faire
déjouer sur un radiateur ou à l'entrée
du four ou dans l'eau chaude
il faut attendre le temps voulu mais
pour être sûr de ne pas se tromper et
bien c'est très simple il n'ya qu'à lire
ce qui est écrit sur l'emballage ou
toutes ces précisions sont données vers
narbonne caire une information vient
d'arriver
une nouvelle importante de dernière
minute les premières asperges ont fait
leur apparition ce matin sur le marché
de cavaillon il s'agit d'un lot de trois
boîtes d'un kilo chacune mise en avant
par un agriculteur au prix de 20 francs
la boîte mail interac sûrement merci
bien sûr je ne sais si c'est ainsi qu'on
pêche les poissons surgelés mais voici
des pêcheurs qui plonge sous la glace un
reportage de nos correspondants de nancy